you look taller
me yeah thank you
that's six six six eight just shut up
brian
what are you six nine yeah chin just
been drinking uh you look like you're
six nine
are you six are you six seven cheers
you're skinnier six nine chin's gotten
thin
it looks great it's a good look for you
thank you chin you have lost a [ __ ] load
of weight literally yeah but it looks
good he's never been fat and also you
don't work out but you look like you
work out just got good genetics yeah you
lean if he lifted weights he'd be you'd
be [ __ ] awesome dude if you lift the
weight you look exactly the same hey
so brian i think he put on muscle hey
hey hold on chin you're doing your
concert this weekend
uh yeah it's your first concert with you
in a little browse first one a little
browse where's it at
well thank you for bringing up that's
pretty cool it's uh portsmouth
it's actually a question
i think it's i think it's cool that you
bring stuff up you brought up my youtube
channel so it's really cool you do that
so thank you
uh
portsmouth ohio which i don't know where
that is going out there is there's a
place called in there there's a place
called vern rife center
and uh yeah that's where it's from
there's like there's like an event every
year so we're just headlining that event
so that's cool yeah but there's a yeah
there's a bunch of how many songs are
you singing
19. we have like 45 minutes set and it's
45 minutes set yeah what are your
original songs uh
i think two three originals and i'll do
two covers
yeah they have a lot of yeah
doesn't do anything i don't know who
little lebron is but
okay super talented guy yeah he's only
been doing this for about good morning
brian little brown uh
you've never seen little brother any of
his music videos nothing
he did the thick boy song he did oh i
know you hear all the songs yeah yeah i
was like you know brian has no idea who
he is no i do because i just know that i
bring him with tick-tock things
again
we were talking about that this morning
i still think that kid's gonna make it
right i think you know what i think you
already made it it makes more money than
you do he what he had what two million
views twenty one twenty twenty one one
video twenty one million yeah he's fine
he's like you let me do what he's
killing it yeah
i don't know kids man uh brian but yes
as we were talking before we started
uh about the deadlifts you know because
i i know you're interested in doing them
but uh
well what's what about me is you guys
are talking about deadlifting and mark's
out there and you got here we deadlifted
and he's got calluses on his hands and
his hands are a little ripped up and all
i can think about right now is going
home and doing deadlift on a straight
bar you want to do it well also i should
also mention remember when i told you
guys that my house got broken into and
that my my weight might have a bar and
all the weights were on yeah i'd
skeptical hip ice from the jump i just
didn't want to ruin your story 455 or
495 on my bar i could never lift that
well
my buddy today goes hey try to get 500
on that bar i can only get 4.95
and i go
excuse me and he goes yeah guy i always
want to put all the chairs half the
chairs on your table and went up and put
books on there there you guys have a
buddy and i went was he watching your
house i went
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
[ __ ] oh i'd fight him no that's you
know what happened
my
my neighbor was responsible for closing
the house up well
he hit the
gate open the gato was open he never
closed the garage door my buddy rolls up
at his motorcycle and goes hello where
is everybody
goes in there joking around does that
stuff the weights took a picture of it
and sent it to me
didn't go through
oh
wait why did he [ __ ] with all the stuff
in the house i don't know it really it's
not your friend i got really mad about
it it's not your friend do i know this
guy no you thank god and i was like what
are you doing
that [ __ ] that's not a friend
that is i read him the riot act
because
what are you doing yeah hey
what are you doing he's also he's also
on a motorcycle yeah show up to your
house in the middle afternoon yeah you
lose it
are you saying no no no no you don't
have a job loser he's hanging out also
also
if it's a guy that i've never heard of
yeah it's your friend huh you're not
your friend yeah
he's not your friend
it's a guy he's a guy dude i if
if chin did that to my house i'd come in
here and beat the shadow chin
if he's like hey when you left i broke
in your house [ __ ] up with all your
stuff what are you doing all right i
mean
that's automatic fight yeah on site dude
i'm gonna don't well i don't have any
friends that do that yeah
i just couldn't think of doing that to a
friend
just decided not even loser because he
had time to do all that
he did a lot and they didn't call
someone like hey man i broke into
brian's house you know brian i'm [ __ ]
with all this stuff you didn't have a
friend go oh don't do that don't do that
because that's not funny and also
it's also weird it's just weird you guys
loose candle
you're reading everything correctly
right now yeah a loser
hey
now listen
on the job he's in your house in the
middle after
disorganizing your [ __ ] maybe he was
riding to work no no i tried to give him
benefit i'm sorry
uh
let's find him
yeah
you give him a slap around
you give him a little slap around little
shove around shove him up you know
what's good about being as strong as
yours you could give a guy a shove up
and that means you just you just get him
moving around in a corner somewhere hey
what did you do when he was like it was
me
i said that's not cool my girl didn't
sleep well you dummy he goes but i took
a picture and sent it i go well no you
didn't because i don't have it hey
that's also allowed i don't have it but
it's also 2021 you know like
it'll go through the picture would
eventually go through right and he's a
liar
did he say that brian yeah he did
hey
i'm asking one more time i'm gonna give
him one i'm gonna give him one chance
and i'm gonna check i'm gonna ask you
one more time
yeah did he say that i promise he did
they said he said a picture never went
through yes
and he has an iphone yep no picture came
through
but the pictures they eventually go
through right a lot of pictures on there
you guys what's come on oh you guys are
[ __ ] oh
it doesn't go through as an eye message
it goes through my own head yeah
brian said
i've never met this guy never he's not a
friend
uh he's just he's just a guy he's a
friend you see my favorite kenny it's
like what's up no no i've known him a
long time
we lived together
lived in my garage
maybe you still want to live in your
group i've already said too much
so he knows the person
no
no
um
hopefully here's a very strange behavior
coming from an adult i don't get it yeah
he's your age
older
older that's fantastic
i know yeah and what can you do man uh
yeah
well chappelle went for a personal pr
today of 500 and then uh
he could have got it and then he was
scared so we had to lower the weight
it's a lot of weight
it's a lot of [ __ ] weight first of
all 500
five hundred but my pr is four oh five
well i heard you did 455 easily and i'd
like to see this change
i wish we had his attempt of 500. he
literally just let his fingers and then
goes no
no
let me see this now you're very strong
but let me just see something i like
your form i like i like your form yeah
yeah
hey dude hey dude
way more yeah 500. you're going to do
500
how do you call him a soy boy here baby
sandwiches
he didn't catch the soil well he needs a
little he needs some confidence he's got
his henry rollins shirt on he's got his
black flagship listen it's okay yeah
dude you got no problem with 455. to be
honest you're putting 500 pedals you
could do reps with that you know that
yeah
to be honest it it's kind of scary okay
i'm scared of passing out yeah i'm
getting lightheaded have you ever passed
out from working out with us ever no but
i've seen those videos who gives a [ __ ]
i've seen videos of you
look this isn't you're not going to pass
out you're not going hard this is new
for you and you're in you're you're
moving weight and you're also a cautious
human being is very close it's not a bad
thing you're a cautious human being and
you're thinking about things like
popping yourself
cautious yeah what do you mean
you're around me all the time i'll tell
you why i think he's cautious you're
around me all the time he doesn't
venture it's hard for for chappelle to
venture out of
into the unknown that's why he tends to
stick to music he sticks to his
interests
in fact right there he goes okay i like
this i like this so for chappelle to
step outside of his comfort zone the
psychiatrist well it's okay and i love
you for it
you're a sensitive dude yes and you're
and you and i'll tell you something else
the reason you're cautious is because
you have a good imagination and when
people have a good imagination they tend
to come up with ways things can go very
wrong yeah right
now especially with working out yeah
and and uh but sometimes i think you're
cautious
i think brennan's cautious but you just
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i know he was like what he goes
what's the worst that's gonna happen
you're gonna fail people
i said chappelle demonstrating you and i
like i didn't even warm up and she did
500 pounds that's just probably you know
what they're screaming i don't give a
[ __ ] dude if i don't get it i don't care
if you guys make fun well you're top no
you're also a little bit tougher you're
gonna try to put yourself in a
comparison with me when it comes to
working you did two things one time
brendan did two things when i when i
that i knew he was different he was
willing to
when he was willing to stand straight
and he said just fall back and hit the
ground
so just fall all the way back you talk
about that that's why
but just fall and don't don't get caught
because because we're trying to shoot
the angle and he goes well just do it
and i go but i'll hit the ground and
really hurt myself yeah and he goes be a
[ __ ] he goes just do it i was like
that's not something i can do i think
that would really yeah that would really
hurt you yeah i'm standing and you want
me to just fall back and hit my back
that's also for our tv show yeah but
that would hurt wouldn't it happen
if he broke a hip yeah so i was like i
need i need padding and he goes you're a
[ __ ] then
then you're right i've ridden horses as
you guys know yeah
you expect
and i throw up
i know horses and i have a healthy
respect for horses okay and we i had to
ride a horse for our thing okay i'll
ride off in the distance three days
we'll just get on and it was there was a
thing that would be funny if we both
fell off and i go well we need stuntmen
and he goes
no we'll just ride
we'll just we'll just
canner and then just fall off together
and i went
but now brendan hold on
there are cactuses and there's rocks
it's ground yeah
it's ground and i don't know about you
know if you the desert has all kinds of
sharp jagged things and you're falling
from a [ __ ] horse like desert he
means calabasas
now we're in ventura county but then he
goes like this he goes he goes
[ __ ] and i go i'm not a [ __ ] we have
to i'm we're you want me to canter and
fall but
to be fair it wasn't like we were just
it was like we're just trying to hike
him like let's fall off these horses for
our tv show
so i know with the budget it's like if
we don't do it then we have to hire two
extras you have to give them more
stuntman yes though two stunt guys so i
i know the budget so i'm like we should
just do it so we'll have to shoot
another day and do all that i don't want
to fall off a horse with you
like that's a big you're a lot that's a
lot of weight you might land on me
so many things could go wrong they've
been so funny but dude that would have
been
many things
the worst for him to fall off a horse
so many things can go wrong yes also
you're falling from a horse it hurts yes
been funny though
falling from uh
hey you want to get to number one or not
on the charts dude you're willing to go
all the way oh yeah
you're willing to go all the way yeah
for that wait so what'd you guys do we
didn't do it we didn't do it i went why
i said we did we delayed the scene yeah
we're not doing that cut the scene we're
not riding fast because you've never
been on a horse
it's dangerous and you had never been on
a horse that's not really no not real
i'm not familiar with was your first
time when you just recently montana yeah
i think when i was like really young i
rode a horse they're all right
all right
you don't give a [ __ ] about anything
well he you say he see he stays in his
world too no no no no though i'm down to
ride a horse shark whatever but then
also you've driven a shark in a
yeah the horse cool
this thing has 900 horses in the [ __ ]
hood no i think it comes from i think it
comes from when you get into a cage in
your underwear in front of all those
people and somebody locks it and you
have to fight a [ __ ] six foot six six
foot seven giant who can knock you out
with a jab
i think everything else is whatever
after exactly your mentality is wrong
your mentality when you have so far with
shane
every day i'd say football was tougher
than that really that was a that was a
[ __ ] excuse me though man your
football was tough a grind but not as
dangerous right man i don't know playing
fullback at cu and the way they treated
me it was tough man okay but i was i was
literally like the kamikaze bomber where
there's like oh we need someone to run
into a wall get called up shop i'm like
what like go run into that guy
all right
okay special teams they used to because
i was the wedge buster which is the
worst job in the world
it's like being on the front it's like
being on the front line when you have
the musket so
they just knew you were a grinder and
happy to be there yeah they're like yeah
we're not worried about what sean would
do like humbling humbling you're just
doing the the [ __ ] work the dummy work
so so they just like the wet so the way
the wedge works now the nfl is pacified
it's the no fun league but it used to be
like the biggest guys would uh when the
ball would be kicked off yeah the
biggest guys would form a wall so and
then the guy catching the ball would you
know they would block everyone and he'd
try and get to the end zone okay so they
you need someone to bust that wedge like
angry birds
you need to fly into that wedge kamikaze
stop so you're you're you're blowing up
the wedge they're they're they're wall
so my guys can get through and tackle
see so i was the that's the same way so
you're the kamikaze yes and you're
you're in the nature the the next the
the monday after the game on saturday
they used to like be like everybody get
together like a shot blow up the wall
you know i was like
i'm glad everybody's having fun with
this but it's so this can't be healthy
you're
and you guys are colliding in the middle
and it's usually like oh linemen or
linebacker that's horrifying the worst
that's horrifying so fighting
[ __ ] you're fighting so you're just
tough man oh and they're they're real
athletes
what yeah they run four fours four fives
so you're
that collision how often are you doing
that a game i mean it depends how many
touchdowns we score what the [ __ ] dude
oh i would never do that see i would
that's too fast
it's intense and then how are you
hitting you're just keeping your you're
pulling your neck and just coming in
what are you
fleeing your flesh and body into the
[ __ ] wall so you're getting wrong
it's bang
concussion
and then and then you're done with
football big disappointment no nfl you
try out for the buffalo bills and then
you go i could play out in the in the in
the indoor league oh yeah i'll go try
ufc and i'm going to fight with shane
carwin who had the biggest hands in the
ufc and the hardest hitter
you guys would just bang
yeah
yeah now
i understand
different mentality it's a tough way to
make a living dude yeah tough football's
[ __ ] tough though dude footballing
all [ __ ]
i mean so you'd say football was was
your heart beating before games more
competitive yeah dude what the on the
line is insane online's insane yeah and
if you do bad you lose your gig
like somebody else can replace you
so embarrassing so many ways to get hurt
and it's so hard to make the team
it's so hard
it's impossible to make the team and
practice i listen fighting i train for
two years in the ufc within four is
ranked in the top ten okay
football i started when i was six and
everybody every great everybody plays
eating yeah and everybody's trying to
play there you're actually colorado so
so i i'm you know the guys on alabama or
like florida ucla i'm a junior i'm a
junior in high school up in
massachusetts wrestling's my thing
and i i want to be i want to be a really
great i want to come back and win
everything yeah i go to dan gable's
wrestling camp
for high schoolers so every kid in the
nation goes to dan gables camp
two weeks and they train you like a
champion you've got the hawk guys there
and you're training
i train for two weeks there where you
wake up in the morning you run sprints
and you do all that like a division all
that [ __ ] you know what happened i went
oh i i don't want to do this oh i don't
want to grind like this have you ever
met like a real like a real collegiate
wrestler like the guys who can't say
that i haven't yet oh they're just like
oh they missed the hooters they're the
yeah but you met him after the fact but
grant you met him as a double uh champ
but it's such a grind it's just like
they're just cut from a different cloth
yeah
like if the taliban came here i just
send out the wrestling that's right
they're the
toughest they're the toughest people in
the world that's right their their
mental capacity to endure pain that's
right and like to get through [ __ ] is
because you're insane you're also
[ __ ] waiting you're also yeah year
round and then to be on like oklahoma
state or oklahoma or iowa or like the
ohio state yeah dude those are those are
the squads when i tell you when i tell
you i limped for two weeks i was limping
because of just the over training and i
did you quit after that i just i was
like if this is what d1 wrestling is and
i went to american university not d1
like oklahoma yeah i was like if this is
what this is where i have to wake up and
sprint and that becomes my full job and
then at the end of four years i'll be
able to shoot a great double leg i mean
i'm not saying it doesn't have its
merits but i was like i just don't think
that's the other thing there's nothing
i'm a famous collegiate wrestler go the
big boy that could do yeah that's his
name yeah that's the problem so the so
they also so that's the other thing
about wrestlers they get no notoriety
they're not getting paid or compensated
yeah you know no one's buying their
jerseys you don't make money off that
nothing there's nothing nothing there's
nothing
that's [ __ ] insane but i tell you
i know a lot of wrestlers like guys that
went to penn state or some of those ivy
league schools are really like harvard
are good at wrestling mm-hmm well those
guys got into harvard because they're
really smart but they have that work
ethic yes then they start companies yeah
and then they take that same work ethic
into the business world and they smash
it well what they do is they give jobs
to those other wrestlers mm-hmm that's
[ __ ] dope so you see some business
that's that's
millionaires yes
yes and i know a wrestler his sons were
all
studs he used to and he was older and
him and his sons used to wrestle with
the pro team up in boulder he'd fly
private everywhere like his kid went to
i think colgate was just when you see
what like how the iowa team trains that
those hawkeyes how they wake up at 5 30
in the morning and that's their first
practice and they're practicing till 7
30. they're the toughest people in the
world and and then they have another
practice in the afternoon and one
metcalf won this kid in mecca won the
ncaas
he won the [ __ ] national championship
and they were interviewing him and he
was like disappointed in my performance
though there are a lot of things i
didn't execute we just won
just one that's the other thing about
wrestling like there's no showboating
like there's no bragging there's no
that's not that's like it's like
baseball it's super frowned upon which
is one of the reasons why it doesn't
unfortunately it doesn't cross over into
pop culture like gets more because
because people like to see that like
yeah you no dude damn and that's why
when you see guys like dan cormier or or
uh
curly hair ben askren
when you become an olympian the kind of
pain you've put your body through
the kind of competitive spirit you have
to have and the ability to grind on that
level is
it's just very rare that's why
like if you have a kid and you're like
man what should i get him into wrestling
like if you look at the ufc champions
everywhere most of the time they have a
wrestling background like anyone who's
successful has a wrestling background
yeah because it translates yep
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] that's intense it's
intense yeah that's it they're tough
speed on the wall yeah literally i get
it yeah
yeah so quit trying to give me the
deadlift 500 then no you could do that
you're just a soy boy about it you're
just putting it
yeah what does it say
a swipe
well this is actually a wikipedia on it
so it says so boys are pejorative
characters yeah
characteristics
like our government is they're soy boys
we're the laughing stock of the [ __ ] all
because of 500 pounds i'm a soy boy well
you just you're putting that 500 on a
pestle it should have been i get it you
surely gotta be like oh it's not [ __ ]
like just do it a little bit just get
bear bear down better
but but i told chappelle like when he
saw me do 600 i went it's a fight dude
i'm not going to get this easy i can't
do 601 yes i can i can't do 601 yes i
can maybe get 600. i said you're going
to see me it's gonna be a fight so every
every fiber of your being has to be
focused on my my nuts are helping me my
[ __ ] lots of [ __ ] everything
i get so i get it now like with the it
looked easy for me to do that even
though they say deadlift is the best
exercise yeah if you could only do one
just do that three times a week yeah and
then right up right after we did our
like pr's like mark had us do what was
so we always do we always go really
heavy and then we end with we did 12
sets of three yeah at like four every
minute
it's good that you're doing this
yeah yeah you keep doing this
with like with me and mark like we know
our way around the weight room so he's
with us so mark he has no choice they're
like the best i think they're like the
best thing for me when it comes to like
the they are the whole you're talking
about the way you're talking about guys
who've been lifting for every time i
look at this like i said earlier like
listen we live you know we do all the
[ __ ] workouts when i see this
[ __ ] deadlift it's the [ __ ]
wildest thing i go what if you work if
you work at it in two years you could be
doing 600 pounds
true or false no maybe
he can do 500 right now so maybe yeah if
you if we had a plan you're strong dude
a hundred pounds more is a lot but
that's a lot well that's i just thought
it's all right
but you can do it i would love to bench
500 but putting 75 pounds on my back but
you did uh
4.25
yeah pretty easy you did it pretty easy
dude pretty damn i feel like you got i
did 405 for four i feel like you have
450 in your back pocket right now yeah
me
it's so heavy it's heavy
it's heavy but i feel like i feel like
you've got a 405 i do feel for at 454.
because i saw that i studied that 425 i
studied it and i even said to you i
texted you and i said
you can do more than that
you did send me something
hilarious yeah
is that what i said that 425 he's like
dude
be careful your shoulders come on shut
up come on now i've been to this like
you know you never you've never felt
anything with your shoulders from
benching right i've been doing it too
long man so i'm saying
like i mean i guess i haven't been doing
it that long today i'll post a video for
my la shows this friday and saturday and
we have a very special guest dropping in
for that um but
i was going to read that
because i'm i'm checking up on him right
so so you know with the whole car wreck
like brian is like it's it's been
so heavy and like
the response that we've got
is
i mean if if you want to make me cry
that will do it like the if you go to
the the poor ladies go fund me who
passed away here and start it all the
comments are firing the kid fans go and
find the kid yes
pittsburgh it's like all fire in the kid
fans like yeah t-fat army uk salsa and
t-fat k t fat k army t fat k uh t fat k
army out of here t back k dallas [ __ ]
amazing uh it's all fine and kid fans so
they're at forty seven thousand guys are
so amazing they're at their goal
and now we're getting so many like great
emails from cops and firefighters oh
yeah
and jason and i do you know i don't read
a lot of social medias but i do read the
emails
do me a favor quit sending me your
horror story that you experience because
it's triggering it ruins my day i love
the emails but when you describe your
horror story compared to i don't it i
think they're trusting i think they're
dealing with their own pts
that's what they say they said i dealt
with this this is how i get over it and
that helps but the horror stories are so
[ __ ] horrific yeah i can't get
through them anymore so with all the
cops and the fine kid fans who you know
donate all this money i can't thank you
guys enough that made me feel there's a
there's a firefighter who also he was a
state uh trooper now um and he samoan
guy from salt lake city and he he sent
me a video saying hey dude you know
brennan has ptsd and he's gonna have it
it's what we live with all the time and
talk to him makes that's why i kept
calling you like i was calling him right
but brian kept calling me text me all
the serious stuff so you know how do you
mean so me and brian joke around and he
like sent me this long like heartfelt
text message and what the [ __ ]
now remember i'm not making light of
this situation at all you have to like
this this is me texting brian only yeah
so he sent me this whole heart like ptsd
you got to talk to somebody i'm here
blah blah this is what i swear i know
how he is and he keeps calling i don't
want to answer them around my kids i
don't want to answer it right so this
one is fine and he and i are the same
because i know what what's going on in
his head is look there's nothing i can
do to help like we can talk but at the
end of the day i didn't talk about
anything like what that's not how we
process [ __ ] yes but also like i also
know it helps to talk right right
if he can't if you can't talk to anybody
it's it's me that's you guys
let your wieners
hang just a little thick size saves
lives so anyway we're talking and we're
like it's all serious you're gonna be
okay this is your thing and this is what
this is a mission to i try to help these
kids
yeah i go that's i go brian goes you're
the hero and then what's right
i go i told you i said you're the hero
this is your role brother okay this is
your role you know be the prince and
then i just get this he goes i know i
know hey real quick between us dot dot
dot i'm a
superhero
and then he goes no i'm reading him he
goes for real i might be batman
which makes you
rob it
you gay
i knew it
he sends a picture of the bad signal he
goes
seriously if you need to get a hold of
me i only respond to this okay which is
that bad signal and i go no please he
goes then i just get this
call me batman in private please
i was like i can't
so that's what we
get that
because i was laughing so [ __ ] hard
i'm a fat man
i saw that [ __ ] artwork someone made
of y'all's batman and robin yeah
and i knew it look at this one and i
kept getting the text and i just kept
watching it unfold holy giant dong's
batman
batman and yeah look at this game look
at his hand
that's genius whoever did this i love
you who did that tom john vaughan bye
man
bye man and robin bye man and robin
that's [ __ ] tom john vaughn you're
awesome i'm batman
yeah
i'm i am batman and you're 50 okay
uh
that's [ __ ] hilarious that is
hilarious
that was funny did i play you my song
shut the [ __ ] up that i wrote and sang
what on stage oh no i'll play it for you
later not
right here no it's stupid and funny but
i'm not going to play it now a little
teaser just a little tiny okay i'll play
it for i can play it for you because i
want to i want to get your idea of how
to make a video of it well we'll tell
you and then let's see if we yeah and
then and then when we do it uh then
we'll do it we'll do i'll do it with the
video and i'll give you after this okay
so that's supposed to be good it's a
joke it's coming well yeah
no i think that was it it's it's gotten
a good response wait are we listening to
it no not right now oh can you sing like
no but it's like you'll see what i mean
anyway
um there's maybe chin can perform it for
you yeah maybe chin yeah
yeah are you nervous about the shows
this weekend of course
i'm always guys been rehearsing
every week yeah yeah it's been a minute
why did you don't do the first show in
l.a
uh i had no idea and then also one of
chappelle's dudes is helping us out with
uh i think did you help us with this one
or oh no he uh i think a show in phoenix
yeah so we have like three shows lined
up already which is insane where is it
ohio phoenix rails and then austin the
same weekend you're in uh houston oh
nice that'd be fun
houston no san antonio
oh no sorry san antonio when your stan
is telling you we're going to go to
austin some place in austin look at the
weather at houston right now we already
looked at it bubba yeah there we go we
already looked at it
it wasn't that hot
yeah shut up you don't remember this
that's the last thing i searched
all right we got rain 82 a little bit of
rain i'll be there a little bit of rain
bro see me it's not bad ooh it's rain
though
rain but just a little bit of rain am i
dealing with rain the whole weekend no
just in the afternoon well there's that
hurricane
oh yeah there's that hurricane is it
going to hit houston is the question so
when you're there it's going to be hot
95 95 95 90. well there you go and
that's what i expect however houston a
lot of times is even hotter than that
well the humidity humidity yeah the
community gets you yeah who gives a [ __ ]
you're indoors
you know what's name it's like yeah are
you gonna go outside you're not in the
middle of the desert you know people are
talking to the indoor ship annoying no
dude do you not have ac right yeah also
i don't care i don't want to hear about
the weather you're right no it's not
like you chill outside the only weather
that [ __ ] with luxury there's snow like
if you don't like say you're going to
new york and it's like a blizzard then
it's like
the reason i check how humid it is is if
i'm going to be on stage i got to bring
a different yeah i got to bring a lot of
different cat williams
you sweat through your jeans like that
dude i get sweaty i guess so i don't
think i've ever seen something like
daddy moves around i get so sweaty i'm
drenched i know yeah yeah but i don't
think i've ever seen sweat through your
jeans yeah me too i bring a difference
you sweat through that little dick hole
maybe
that's why i always wear black usually
because i sweat so much um
yeah
probably get sweaty
yeah i don't want you to talk about the
weather and i don't like people tell me
about their dreams i don't care about
your dreams
i don't care about your diet your food i
don't care about your workout uh i don't
care about the errands you have to run
uh and also i had a dream last night did
you have a dream last night well that's
not real is it no
no
no it's not
it's not
you leave thursday a big jake gets her
on thursday
really thursday's j dawg i love jay i
don't see him enough i miss him you got
a new puppy i try to get in between you
guys we're brothers
that's so funny
brian's your brothers brothers what are
we doing today
so stupid
he is
well that's it yeah
what do you got you let's take a break
from the chat with the boys because
summer is here and there's never been a
better time to try a shirt from my
friends at ontucket they have
performance shirts that wick the sweat
kids also short sleeve button downs and
polos that are made to beat the heat so
when you out there barbecuing your meat
putting your meat on people's grill you
need to wear on tuck it man their shirts
are perfect for family barbecues dinner
with friends vacations look fly on
vacation with the on tuckett shirt use
code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
untuck it make sure it's ready
to be worn untucked they have all shapes
and sizes untucked it offers up to
xxxl they have slim for you skinny boys
out there to relax tall fits onto it has
85 stores nationwide free returns and
exchanges so go ahead and go to
ontucket.com promo code fighter for 20
off what's up kids just announced i had
to cancel my north carolina dates i
apologize we will reschedule for january
so i'm still coming but this friday and
saturday i'm at the haha in los angeles
california two shows friday two show
saturday friday i have a very special
guest you all will know and you all love
so that's friday and saturday shop and
friends at the haha in los angeles
california the next week i'm at my
favorite club in the world i'm at the
comedy store in la jolla california
right outside san diego one show
thursday two shows friday two shows
saturday we might add a extra show on
thursday so get your tickets now because
they are selling out don't be crying in
my dms asking for tickets when they're
gone they're gone kids the economy store
la jolla is next week man then san jose
california september 9th through the
11th san antonio texas september 24th
through 25th denver colorado september
30th and october 2nd in las vegas nevada
october 7th through october 9th tickets
at fatkz.com or thickboy.com this
episode of fighting the kid is brought
to you by audit supplements what do you
need bro alpha brain new mood total gut
health you got to protect your gut man
got to protect your gut how about we
have some shroom tech immune everybody
all worried about their immune system
with this delta variant poppin protect
yourself get your immune system poppin
all right we have protein powder
coffee krill oil joint oil fitness for
your thick ass we have onyx kettlebells
on it on demand workouts streaming
fitness club maces quad maces steel club
steel maces we got it all man battle
ropes on it.com slash fighter for temps
off the entire god damn website on it
dot com slash fighter 10 off what are
you guys doing with jay by the way when
you guys get here we still have shows
well because we're supposed to be in
north carolina and the blues got
rescheduled so jay has a ticket anyway
so is the hurricane hitting north
carolina i guess hurricane delta
it's east coast it's just a [ __ ] show
out there so it doesn't make sense for
me to go and delta so the delta variant
is got i guess you look at the numbers
it's not bad
no but you know i don't i don't be
responsible for spreading delta again
i don't need those you don't need those
problems did you hear about new zealand
they shut back down after they went into
lockdown i think it was new zealand
after one case
one case they locked down one case they
don't [ __ ] around was it new zealand
yeah i think it was new zealand well
they were super super strict so yeah
they stopped around yeah but also they
they had opened up earlier before we did
they were like doing there's there's
some there's some bands i like out there
and they were doing like i had bad
issues they never had bad issues but
yeah there's some bands i like out there
i don't know i don't get why
we just don't do what sweden did have
you seen the swedenborg yes and i like
no one wants to talk about it i know
tell me about it they never shut down
anything
and they said old people you guys got a
quarantine they took the people at risk
which we've known forever and those are
the people that they quarantined yes
but they didn't lock down and guess what
that they did not have a spike in death
neither did uh england like london when
the delta hit they're like all right
we'll get through this and now it's
however i'll say this about london when
you go there they are
super strict so you you have to have a
covet test three days before you go okay
you have to be you don't have to be
vaccinated you have to have a test uh
eight days after you're there
and they call you when you get there you
have to quarantine they call you they
track your phone
so if they show up at where you're at
and you're not there you're in some
serious trouble did you see trump last
night on fox news no oh he went hard in
the paint he did oh my god he went you
forget like i know he's crazy but you
forget how much of a better talker he is
than biden like oh my god oh yeah he
released the hounds he did oh my god i'm
biting he's like this this is the worst
tragedy in in american history you know
we're strategy american history where we
did in afghanistan these porn is you
know he's just sticking it to him did
you and then they go whoa biting us
listen he didn't know what's going on
he's not he's like he goes who knows
who's making the calls he said he's not
he's not doing it
did you see what that was that tick tock
or whatever it was where they come here
hey brian no my nephew was showing hey
my nephew showed it to me my nephew no
more
the difference between
biden i mean and no i'm sorry obama and
trump when they talk about the same
thing where binds like he he was uh
osama bin laden was uh given a burial at
sea
and and just cut obama he died like a
dog i died like a dog that's that's
trump's problem
he's so hard oh [ __ ] it's so you know
the name of the tick tocker i i can find
it we were laughing so hard the guy was
laughing oh we're pulling up the tick
tock if i can find it i typed in the
biden and trump thing didn't work oh
that's [ __ ]
[Music]
brian you're more educated than me i saw
that
obama when he was in office he let go
the head of the taliban is that true or
is that just yeah he did he traded him
he traded him
bernthal yeah so do you think if he
never did that well the guy spent from
2002 to 2014 in guantanamo bay i mean
and hadn't been actually accused of a
crime he was just considered close to
osama bin laden he was not
years ago yeah yeah available that's the
beginning or the or the taliban realizes
that there's not a whole lot of profit
in that kind of behavior and it might
make sense oh you're adding more money
to
come into the fold a little bit no not a
chance well it's like they were saying
like they were interviewing one guy from
taliban that and you know cnn's run with
their like actually taliban's opening
given women rights yeah and then they
showed them a woman with refused to wear
the turban and was talking about women
rights well they shot her in the face oh
[ __ ] so they're erasing all pictures of
women in there in uh afghanistan too
uh did we enjoy the clip of the lady
talking about the taliban we did that
yeah where she was like they're shouting
death americans but they actually seem
pretty cool yeah she's on the street
you're like oh what yeah this is a
reporter yeah yeah it was real yeah yeah
it's just it's like a white reporter
like
americans yeah because she's in the
whole at the end of the day she's like
they're shouting death to americans but
they seem pretty cool the worry is that
the country falls into civil war yeah
and and and again and uh because you
said that there's tribes it's it's
tribal i talked to some guys who are
over there and like are knee-deep in
that [ __ ] and i said uh because we were
doing the king's thing yesterday we were
talking about i wanted to get a little
facts on it because you know we don't
nobody here knows what the [ __ ] going
on
and they said it was it's it's a good
idea to get out of there but not the way
we did yes they said the way we did it
was not the best the big lesson though
is this with all our intel
you know all our intel and all all the
all the policy people who study this
what what i think is very significant is
that none of them
none of them saw the country falling
they were all off quickly yeah and we
were talking about our experts who they
were all are basically calling the shots
like bindings just like
it was it fell in 11 days and no one saw
that we thought and four days 60 of the
country was taken over four days what
does that mean what that means is that
the taliban as we call them have
enormous amount of sympathy among the
people in that country because a lot of
the a lot of the effort wasn't reaching
a lot of those people
so
you have to take that into account right
yeah it's a little bit like the way the
viet cong in vietnam
had so much sympathy then people weren't
didn't have allegiance to saigon
and it was like well that you have to
look at what's really going on in the
hearts and minds of the people and
that's hard but they they had a retired
uh four-star general on the other day
and
and he was just talking about he's like
like the taliban and the people in
afghanistan they don't want americans
there like so we have so much power with
that
we before we just dipped out and [ __ ]
like there's like they think they don't
know the reports they think there's
between 10 to 30 000 americans stuck
over there now so he's like
it would've been so much easier to go
all right we'll leave you have our word
but we have to get all these people out
as soon as they're out then we'll leave
yeah because they want us out so bad
they've been like all right cool fly
everybody out that's fine and we
could've got everybody out but instead
of doing this knee-jerk reaction like
all right we're out people are [ __ ]
dude yes [ __ ] now i did hear that and
those are experts that were in biden's
air given they had no idea and had no
idea
you know but a lot but the guys who were
the military they have ideas
yeah but they're not they can't they
don't have the presence there
afghanistan has always been that
whirlpool you get sucked into you try to
go in there with a light footprint as we
said and you still get sucked yeah it
goes
even the some of the russians tried to
take it over what years ago
the 80s 70s genghis khan alexandria
great who else the russians nobody
nobody conquers afghanistan i've got the
british now remember those and those
taliban they're only like thirty five
thousand strong
seventy five thousand about they they
don't they don't know the exact number
so
roughly that seventy five
seventy five thousand took over the
country and there's three hundred
thousand and an air force plus an air
force
we took the air force and their drones
away so that's a little tough but they
did have seventy five thousand over
three hundred thousand that's how good
of fighters then yeah
well
also the country itself the towns the
the military massive desertions they
were just like i'm not fighting those
guys i'm not killing those guys i know
those guys i know those guys i don't
know you america yeah yeah i know yeah
but it's not in that a we know them and
b they're better fighters than us and
see we really don't know what the [ __ ]
we're doing so we're going to die what
is that expression it's one thing to
know what you're fighting against we
went in there and i i agreed with why we
went in there because they were
harboring our enemies al qaeda and i i
supported that 100 percent that that's
what we were fighting against terrorism
and we believe the problem is yes we
beat it we beat it the problem is you
have to ask yourself if you're there for
20 years what are you fighting for and
when you don't know what you're fighting
for that's very you're saying if you're
if in afghanistan if you're american
well if you're american you're fighting
so that doesn't come back
that right that's right but it seems to
me that we did that after we bombed tora
bora and they already went into
waziristan pakistan and so
you know we turned our our
we had all that military machinery and
who was there the taliban who'd never
killed americans we turned on them and
then we got ourselves whether we knew it
or not into a type of civil we we took
sides even though we tried to use the
northern alliance to do it blah blah
blah this is dicey man it's dicey it's
what vitamin be remembered for for sure
it's what he will be remembered for i
don't fault him before pulling out
ultimately i fault him for the way he
pulled out that's what always everybody
always says i just think it's very
significant that no one saw it falling
that quickly and that's why none of us
knew what was really going on in the
hearts and minds of average afghanistan
yeah so what do you get jen yeah
that's on that agenda a lot of bracelets
there's just two one's a necklace i just
put it off well you know what three
you're crossing the road in in at
nighttime whatever it is we can see you
if you're hunting
you're you're a liability
by the way i've been you're a musician
now yeah welcome um so i saw a bunch of
different youtube videos as well
uh you know people that were served in
the army in afghanistan
and they were saying a bunch were saying
like they the government everyone knew
that this was going to happen and they
knew it was going to happen faster yes
and they just did it
anyways
uh let's start with
do you think he'll pay a political price
for it biden yeah oh yeah oh yeah i saw
that uh
hey and i heard uh cobbler harris they
they have like people in the house that
she was shouting like you're not gonna
put this on me this is yours of course
because she's the most ambitious person
on the planet but she's also the most
disliked vice president of all time
correct so if you think biting's gonna
pass away and she steps up you're you're
sorely mistaken yeah people can't stand
her i even when she was running people
didn't like like figure it out
condescending
shots are terrible just the worst
i read that uh if they did like a
re-election after everything that just
happened that trump like if biden and
trump had a re-election that trump would
have what the approval ratings trump
would have won believe that i could say
that he's so polarizing though trump's
so polarizing
yeah i like a lot of stuff trump did but
it just it just separated the nation
like yeah like i'd rather i don't want
to deal with that no i like his policies
way better than bidens but we were so
like america was so divided so divided
and it was it was like heartbreaking yes
which no one's worth that right yeah
let's get somebody else in there who's
less divisive there has to be something
those [ __ ] two idiots ron desantis
ron desantis is the man i i'm not yeah i
i think he's great he could win
i mean i think he's great
okay um
i'm sure you guys have seen this video
by now i haven't yes i have it this is
insane so this is a an alligator handler
and they're doing some sort of birthday
party thing where you know they're
feeding the alligator and there's kids
watching too yeah it'll bring out
there's a birthday party though
also you dummy no it's it's a it's a
place where they have those animals out
yeah yeah so the kids just went to the
facility
they say the hardest bite
and so there's there's no video there's
a video yeah i'll show you the video
here you see
this girl is freaking she's a boss
so it's her alligators yeah she's the
one that handles this particular
alligator
it's darth gator that's his name
kind of [ __ ] me up the size of that
thing these kids are probably like ah
[ __ ] and you could take a look at i'll
show you in a bit
take a look at this kid in particular
well look at this jersey is he worth
number two
[Applause]
so she grabs her hand
he's done this before
oh he's rolling yeah and she rolls with
him yeah you got it
she's got that jiu-jitsu grip on him and
this guy's
this guy's awesome too
that one kid was down for the show yeah
he thought he was part of the show he's
watching the kid too
hey hey dude get a stick and pry that
jaw open
i mean i'm sure everyone's just like
what the hell just happened it's an
alligator dude
don't [ __ ] with an alligator he's
choking it looks like he's doing yeah a
rear naked sort of
that alligator is like i don't know what
you guys expect dude her composure she's
such a boss yeah her composure yeah she
wrapped her legs around the [ __ ] i
like the guy who's doing nothing
i don't know what that was in my black
shirt because i know a lot of things
been holding her hand
look at her holder yeah she's just kind
of just [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
do you need another body hey you hey you
hey boy
he got in the lime green shirt get your
[ __ ] soy boy get it
water get a crowbar and [ __ ] open
that thing dude knife and [ __ ] pierce
this thing in the [ __ ] guilt you know
what cut its [ __ ] throat
kill it there oh let's go there you go
and watch out
super calm
yeah her composure was [ __ ] now this
guy has to worry about the alligator and
then she's guiding him through what to
do look he's all right on right on okay
uh i'm here by myself
oh [ __ ]
she's so calm
look at her doing her thing
[ __ ] amazing he's stuck in there
what's going on
no no
watch your hand
is that thing in a bite i don't want to
turn around and bite him i love his
dad's shoes
and bam
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] that girl's a badass what
happened to her arm they want to see the
pictures right now yeah yeah
y'all gonna look here
i am oh it's not terrible yeah mark's i
thought it was worse than that
i think it's made to each her she's a
she's a badass that's alligator doing
alligator [ __ ] that's an alligator doing
alligator [ __ ] yeah and i find her
attractive hopefully they didn't put
that i knew you would that's your time
this
is
she's beautiful please stop doing that
yeah that's just too close that's so
stupid if it gets your face
that's that same alligator yeah and her
after no that's before this is happening
but she's still got her hand
she's got a body too she's gorgeous yeah
but i don't want her to get hurt yeah
this is what we're going to get
alligators like this [ __ ] is stupid
what's happening well you can't be you
talk about it
how did you get there because that's
what she's doing she's all why do you
you know you know the problem with this
this [ __ ] dead lifting and all this
tea what you're aggressive as [ __ ] do
you think yeah you yeah you call them
you get yourself you get a little like
it comes in you like what they i'm just
saying she's [ __ ] having tits all up
in this alligator's face she doesn't she
had her face and her hands up she's all
up on that alligator like you would you
mean but that thing but also that's what
you get get your face away but also
that's what you get though right
strongest bite is that what you said
brian stronger maybe they have the
strongest is it the cheetah
no not the no it's a cheeseburger i
think it's a crocodile oh no is it a
panther no it's the alligator alligator
american allergy bring up hardest bites
big cats don't even uh
the um hyenas have harder bites than
so that was no salty that salt that's an
hour
but the alligator is not far behind
now that's salty that's what's scary
is there a top 10 list
well hey there you go just scroll down
there which animals bite the hardest
hit it
great white shark hippo
jaguar number four brian yeah but i
think uh i think that american
alligators are right there oh they're on
the top ten though no i think they are
no they're not though no i think they
are no there's all this saltwater
great white standard hippo knew it no
hippo yeah jaguar
oh my god that'd be scary oh my god oh
this just [ __ ] kisses me
they all bite [ __ ] hard they all bite
hard dude they kill things with their
face okay
and that's what that lady handling is
like that's what you get though you know
what's funny is it's not funny but when
you watch lions attack uh a giant fight
in water buffalo that's a big male and
the big male's just sitting there
shrugging them off well lions their
lions go right for the old testicles
they'll bite them right off
they like to attack from the back you
got to eat this and the big nuts they
don't have to deal with them head-on big
black nuts yeah whoa it's black
like big black nuts
nuts
yeah bigger than that i'm talking heavy
black nuts heavy black and so the lions
don't know they're like oh look at these
pair of nuts
delicious
all right
yeah that's just you want this
i want you to try it since you never
have anything
what is it so truly remember you talked
about julie's
what is it you talk smack on julie's
it's a lemonade truly it's just a star
yeah just give it a shot so you know if
you drink it
what yeah dude seltzer's forget
that have you had himself no it's
science i read an article on it what do
you mean i have to i i'm not going to
want to suck your dick if i drink
because you swallow the gravy baby is it
like one of the white collars
illumination
oh yeah i'm going to have a mom
i'm telling you dude i'll try and get
the frat houses
we don't know what happened we're
drinking some white claw next thing you
know we're sucking each other off all
right let me see i'm sure
swallow it's tasty right swallow now
look at my dick
thirsty much i hold the hole's daddy's
thirsty
daddy's thirsty you got a hole in the
pants i don't think i have it
you have a huge arrest
let me try it how is it i don't think
you're gonna i mean
no it doesn't make me gay i've already
had whiskey
oh
so i have the blocker for it
i'm drinking buffalo trace the reason
it's good because it's like no carbs no
sugar no no no
it's like a mike's heart yeah yeah it's
like a mic sorry just sugary though or
like uh
smearing off ice
yeah not like girl girls yeah yeah
it's not good
that's a 12 year old girl yeah i got
[ __ ] up off of those on uh fight
companion you got [ __ ] up off with
your 20s
yeah i well i had like a whole 12 pack
to myself really yeah but no one else is
drinking those it's fine but there's
there's alcohol in it five percent
alcohol first if you don't get you some
arrogant bastards dude 140 pounds dude
the next fight can be and play [ __ ]
edward 40 yeah dude i'm doing this that
was my i'm down what's that that's my
[ __ ] and count you you you ducked out
40s to your hands you can't take it off
do you finish them
one of you has to help me go to the
bathroom though then
what did you say one of you will have to
help me go to the bathroom and then that
happened and i haven't had that i
haven't done that there it is edward
forty hands i got you that guy probably
made some terrible mistakes
like rob shine yeah that doesn't look
like and it's cold too so your hands go
numb
i'll do it you've never done it no i'm
not a beer you didn't go to college
right i went to santa monica for like
college for like two years so i'm not
like you again you didn't go to college
right basically no chin i sent it to you
all right
edward 40 hands is a great game well i
used to get down and dirty on some bed
with 40 hands that [ __ ] yeah what did
you say
what did you study in college um
marketing and advertising there's no
calorie whiskies or vodka whiskers are
too hard especially if i want to just
you know chill
but i do i told you i chased the whiskey
with the heart seltzer that's the edward
40 hands champ that's that's not even is
that what kind of tape is that i don't
know what kind of it's like trash bag
sure you didn't get out of it yeah
i couldn't pee
no you gotta have someone to help you
you gotta have someone healthy part of
the game
but i was edward forty hands champion
find a hot chick like [ __ ] i'm tired
that's crazy right there i used to do
that that's way too much taste
when i was in college this was in
college when i used to get down with
like 240s at night just [ __ ] hydrated
butt ice wow just [ __ ] rocking wow
and where we are in college it was a dry
county so we had to drive like
a distance college was dry county this
was in texas jesus christ the junior
college it was in a small town god who
called
up for that
scholarship [ __ ] them a dry [ __ ]
county
isn't pepperdine not that pepperdine is
a dry county
he goes [ __ ] damn
just going bad on the whole college like
you just said he's on his heels and he's
like this he's like it's a scholarship
though and he goes yeah dude what's the
[ __ ] dry county yeah it was dry
county because i got a scholarship [ __ ]
that
who the [ __ ] because
you tell me your kid to a dry county
college i don't know maybe i don't make
bad decisions dude it was the 30 minute
drive to get alcohol that's it that's
not bad no it's very funny [ __ ] hey
it made it all part of the phone just
you got mad at the town
[ __ ] that what town is it it's called
athens wait the whole town is dry
it was a dry county why you got i like i
don't know why i've never heard of that
watch what could type in dry county
here's my over under is news from
getting recruited yeah hey larry
ellison yeah i love him a lot a lot of
drug counties are in this house larry
elder i like him me too but did you get
a thing to vote in the mail i think they
know we're going to vote for larry so we
don't get him i don't i didn't i do you
like larry elden me too i read he's i
have a book i'm i was listening to his
book um it's a good book too um that he
wrote i'm yeah
i'm voting for i'm voting for larry
ariel is [ __ ] larry ella have you
ever seen uh dave rubin said well
there's a lot of racism and larry elder
who's back and he said well give me an
example yeah i love this where racism
like just give me an example of where
it's actually
stopping someone from doing something
it's not that racism doesn't exist it
does but he's trying to get an example
of how that stops and there is an answer
to that i'm not saying there isn't you
definitely but it was funny because dave
was a smart guy and i i
i really like dave and dave was like he
talks about in his book he was like i
couldn't i was like uh
well and he goes give me an example i
just waited and dave was like i was
[ __ ] embarrassed have you seen larry
at and he doesn't know there's cameras
on and a kid's wearing uh
save black women it's a white kid's
shirt
and he goes up to the kid he goes what
do you what do you uh what do you mean
by say a black woman that's a white you
know
what woke left [ __ ] idiot and uh
there you go what do you mean say black
girl and the kid goes you know what i
mean menus
give me an example
he goes well you know like they're just
in general you know you keep saying that
you're pretty general i need a specific
example of how we can help black women
and i'll i'll help you out here let me
know what your example is and the kid's
like
and he goes uh uh like uh the the pay
gap there goes the pay cap do you know
that uh black women and white women too
uh when they start in the workforce
they're they're paid a higher salary are
you aware of those stats the kids like
no he's like let me talk to you
something that takes them aside i love
it and that's how you do it with a young
person yeah he didn't like
talk to you he wasn't mean about it he's
there he's like give me an example he's
there to change he's trying to have
dialogue he deals with real because how
many people do you know they go to these
marches and do all this [ __ ] and they're
on instagram and they're woke left and
if you go dude give me the stats give me
the example they they don't they don't
know what they're fighting for it's
emotional this is
so lost in the world emotions yeah young
emotional people and larry elder who
lived it and stopped this [ __ ] he's a
he's a tell me i get a vote for that guy
look at his [ __ ] teeth i love that
look at his teeth i love larry look at
that little mini fro i am behind mary
elder i like that yeah me too larry all
the way yeah wait chappelle you said
he's a vet oh yeah is he i asked if he
was don't think he's a vet but okay he
might have
had a radio show for a long time and
he's just a very smart guy
and cares and has been involved not
solving problems
he's an attorney okay
yeah born lawrence allen elder
i find it i also find it very
condescending i mean when people when
white kids are young they'll save black
women that's condescending as [ __ ] you
don't they don't need you to save them
get the [ __ ] the i think that a lot of
times the far left talks about black
people like they're victims and they
can't help themselves and i listened to
a bunch of these white people at amazon
i think it was one of those companies
and they were interviewing do you think
voter ids are racist they were like of
course and they why he goes well a lot
of black people can't afford they can't
afford to get an idea and they can't
afford the internet like i'm like you've
never been around
it was so condescending that was a real
thing that was and they were saying and
this one woman goes well they don't
understand a lot of times they don't
understand
that you know this that anything i'm
like you're talking about these people
you've never met them and you're talking
about these people like they're they're
literally that's ninety percent of them
it drives me it's so condescending is
that i can always tell that you don't
actually spend any time with the black
people you're just lost never you
wouldn't drive through those
neighborhoods much less live in them you
wouldn't drive they're just they're just
lost yeah that's all it is and now they
found an identity there and they don't
hurt you signaling [ __ ] you do
know you're not helping it's like
another example is like
if you if you really want to help what
what what are you doing that is actually
helping the people you're talking about
if there's one thing i've learned from
my biological mom growing up
is that because she's she's one of the
strongest women you know
women i know
and one thing that like
you know hit me when i was younger
you know
was just she expressed like to never
play like a victim or like to act like a
victim like after all that i would see
what she would go through
with my uh stepfather you know she would
still
make it to work on of course take
everything she needed to yeah rent on
time and build on time like everything
you know so it's like i learned that
from her yeah you still you know like go
ahead so i read a book on critical race
theory because it's all the rage and
stuff yeah and i read a book so i wanted
to educate myself on it because i don't
agree with it right i don't like the
idea of
of saying this group is more has had a
hard time so we have to treat them
different than this group and your guys
are white so you have to be apologetic
and this is everyone i hate all that
yeah and at the end of the at the end of
the day what i got from reading a number
of uh critical race theorists including
the people that started this this
movement was that they're they're
marxists uh they believe in tearing down
the entire system and that's that's what
they want yeah but what's what's what's
interesting about all of that is that
when when you actually look at what is
going so if you take there are some
interesting things though if you take a
black woman and she wants to get
involved in in civil rights
that woman has a very different
consideration so her considerations are
a lot of times
health care and
daycare for my children when i'm going
to work i need i need somebody who can
take care of my children that i trust
that's going to educate them at when i'm
at work because i'm working two jobs
that's a very real tangible problem for
her okay affordable housing so what
she'll do is a lot of times she'll
she'll go to uh get involved in the
civil rights movement so she'll go to
her local civil rights sort of you know
yeah deep or whatever it was and it's
it's run by a bunch of men and they have
a very different set of considerations
yeah they're dealing with legislation
bigger issues and she's like this is
great but what i need is what about
child care guys yeah and they go well
you're getting in the way stuff
envelopes for now we'll get to that when
we get to that and so the civil rights
movement and equality and all those
movements are
multifaceted like if you say so if you
two guys are walking by a homeless
person and he says well look at that
hobo and the person goes dude
stay homeless man you're that's bad
language
are you doing anything to actually help
that person you're not doing anything
you're not doing she's not doing
anything when you posted black square
are you actually doing anything no and
so the real question becomes
you know you're not actually doing
anything and what you're doing is not
costing me and the reason why
when it comes to that type of stuff is
like
it's all about the dialogue if there's
never any dialogue like what what did
that black square or any of that stuff
like mean it did not it did nothing like
it's all about the dialogue and like and
with when it comes to dialogue you have
to clear out all the emotions and you
have to come to you know some type of
obviously you know understanding but
you know yes you're you're so right like
a lot of times people just say [ __ ] but
it's never
it there's no it's not but but they're
saying because they think it's the right
thing to say they don't really believe
almost as if it's like a but you also
it's like posting that black square on
instagram people you don't post i'm like
no because i'm not racist right like the
white people are posting like do you
think that made the world less racist
what bothers me too is when people talk
about black like when white people say
oh well the black people
you you're acting like black people
agree on all the same [ __ ] no they don't
agree at all you know some black people
like god's people or black
people a lot of black communities i'm
i'm sure you would agree i don't know i
want to hear your take on it but are
pretty conservative like they find that
a lot of them and and there are
different ways like some some black will
be like look i i'm going to assimilate
into the culture of the white culture so
i can accrue economic power and and make
a difference from there and other people
are like no i'm going to be a little bit
more of a black nationalist and i'm
going to stick to certain certain other
expressions that are like that and so
it's just everybody has a different
point of view it's just a different
point just like white people else any
other group and that's fine that would
you know well everybody has like they
say black
yeah because wait america do you hear
what he said actually and some people
are going black yeah he's like you know
like he's like aggressive
yeah
he's like he cracked my rump
black please
you don't give a [ __ ] yeah i don't know
just but like at the same time like the
way you say african-american yeah you
don't have to
whatever but you just like
okay you say black
here's the thing with me brian like
like you you asking me that question i
don't speak for every you don't speak
for everybody speaker i don't speak for
every black girl i i speak specifically
exactly
specifically
you're right it is the dead lips this
morning but you and i are trying to get
out of the bottom
yes
i don't like when bryce says black i
didn't say i said black it triggers me
when he says black
i think it's your teeth i don't know
i'm saying
larry's not gonna like this why i don't
like you swiping my hand i don't like
the way you say black yeah we both don't
know
can you not no for you you know i don't
you know i tell most people just yeah
call me black you call me
african-american yes yes damn that's you
that's the ice that's you you call me
black and why don't you say black why is
the mexican-american the black guy
coming after the white guy right now
african-americans you're telling us how
to feel yeah you're telling me how to
feel you rich wines you privileged you
tell me i'm a victim you grew up on
horses i do ride horses what else you
got
all right cat just sent me this it's a
it's a little bit if it's another
britney thing i'm going to freak the
[ __ ] out
this is going to hit home it's a little
bit of a bummer but tim tebow apparently
released from the jaguars no
he had such a bad first preseason game
you took like four or five years off
playing baseball then tried to jump into
the league
dude you want to talk about a brave
[ __ ] dude man yeah so what do you
play for the highs and even the lows the
opportunities and the setbacks i've
never wanted to make a decision out of
fear or failure i'm grateful for the
chance to pursue a dream thank you the
jaguars and everyone who supported me in
this journey and we know that all right
won't read that so that's cool man yeah
man i'm sorry sorry that tim didn't do
it
i mean you know it's [ __ ] tough to go
from playing baseball into that man
everything he's done this is a huge such
a badass man did he miss a block or
something or yeah
i don't know it's the nfl dude he's 34.
yeah oh [ __ ] stud
don't feel bad for tim
he's going to be fine yeah now i'm going
to have to get rid of that tim tebow
jaguar oh no you got one yeah hell yeah
he says she's for him all the time
he's good people i have the mets the
authentic uh tebow uh match jersey they
sent me oh okay so whenever i wear the
mets it says jersey i love tiffany love
it
really good dude one of the best people
i know yeah
hard worker man i don't know i don't
know football man i just feel like i
just put him on there and i feel like he
could he's so big and strong run out and
just catch balls nope but i don't know
anything about it nope nope nope nope
new rule i'm fine kid yeah don't talk
football yeah fighting or say black i'm
talking
fighting i'll talk football
i'll leave you fighting football and
black don't say black anymore don't say
football i'm not going to talk about
blacks and i'm going to say
and i you know what i don't want chris
say black either yeah
yeah i don't want you oh man it's the
whole bag of vibe yeah
yeah i don't know there's a whole bag of
get up can chin say black yeah yeah yeah
yeah chicken why can't you say black you
know so the two white people can't say
black
maybe that's racist
yeah look at him mainly you christian
mainly you why i said no
let me hear you let me hear you say it
let me hear you say it
january january 6 where were you yeah
yeah yeah see he said the six
you said january 6th all he said was a
sick i don't act like you forgot the
date yeah um you know i was actually
helping my grandparents move out of
their house
they live in maryland but uh nowhere
near uh downtown dc your face i mean
yeah you can't say black anymore jim
what do you got
um speaking of mma
we talked about this okay like around
two years ago remember we heard
katzenganov saying she has something big
coming up when she got released from the
ufc hey can i say this i uh
i don't like how
halle berry's so into ufc something rubs
me wrong about it it's weird yeah yeah
she's always front row so i know w me
owns it and that's probably the
relationship it doesn't seem like she
really likes it get your tits out of my
face in your front row you feel me
it bothers me so what's going on here
though so remember we talked about this
on when it was big brown breakdown i
think uh so captain gano posted
something about she had to not she
couldn't take a fight because something
big was happening and then the ufc
released her right after that so
apparently uh you know the move that's
coming out with halle berry about mma
that now valentina shevchenko has the
leading role yeah that was supposed to
be cats in ghana's role but then
cat thought that so hallelujah get
released from the ufc and still be in
them yes so here's the thing so he she
said that halle berry told her that's
her role and then just you know don't
take that fight you have this role and
then once she was released from ufc
she's like i can't have you in the movie
if you're not from the ufc because ufc
is not going to promote it and plus you
know you want a real ufc fighter to be
in that movie yeah that's not even
that's not even halle berry so they
can't do movies either choice well i'm
sure it's a
wme thing and i think cat just doesn't
know how hollywood but also she had a
fight booked and then she didn't want to
do it yeah yeah you picked the movie
so they released her yeah and then now
she's going to get started
presenter with a big fight uh offer
shortly after the conversation the
berries and ghana alleges that she
discussed the fight off with barry come
that uh halle berry advised her to pass
on the fight if she wanted to star and
bruised sighting liability concerns from
the insurance after agonizing over the
decisions in ghana says she ultimately
passed them
to do the movie
and then the ufc terminator contract
is that a picture who is the picture of
the thing that's how's
yeah
that's tough
i mean she's still gorgeous she's
supposed to be there after that there
she's not there she's not she got
punched but in real life she is yeah uh
what happened so lizzie was crying
during instagram live and she was
talking about
how people are talking about her looks
more than her music but i saw this whole
instagram live video i didn't buy it did
you she was trying to she's like
promoting her song yeah
but i i saw the headline like i do make
some lizzo jokes i'm gonna stop doing it
like you have some lizzo jokes she
definitely gets uh she definitely gets
jokes and stuff like i'm sure but i'm
really sure if she gets people like you
guys
if like because she she'll post you know
she's in a thong and obviously she's a
very very very heavy on very set girl so
it's like you're going to get that
backlash like you're like if you're
going to promote that
body positive [ __ ] you know not
everyone's on board for this
out-of-shape look so you can get some
backlash i saw the clip and i was like
oh man she's just promoters yeah that's
it this isn't genuine at all if it was
just that and not the song i would yeah
yeah you can find her anymore so wait
during this she said yeah check out my
song yeah this song it's super long it's
like 13.
no we don't know why
you don't buy what
this is fake it's not organic like it's
not real like she's crying about like
it's like even the tears like oh man not
the best actor yeah so i'm sure she does
get hurt but i don't think that's why
she made this video i think she made
this video to promote her song because
the song's not doing well so then she
does this so now we're even talking
about it yeah we go lizzy has a new song
so that's why she did it she's just good
at
everything some people do but yeah just
everything and then what they have pr's
that help them like yo you shouldn't she
just couldn't oh she's just this is her
i mean i just think some people are just
really good at turning literally
everything into self-promotion and okay
yeah it's tough she goes i say anything
i want to say i make music that i like
that's important to me i make music i
hope helps people period i'm not making
music for white people i'm not making
music for anybody i'm a black woman
making music i make black music period
no you make music it's not a race thing
yeah
she had the strong words for those body
shaming her for the people that just
always have something negative to say
about me that has nothing to do with
music content my character or me as an
artist
anything to do with my body and whatever
troop trope you think i fall into suck
my
mm-hmm from behind because y'all behind
cause y'all mother effort is going to be
the ones that
catching up she had to point out the
great stars before her
had to deal with the same type of
criticism uh the great artist before had
did he deal with that um
i think
was out there i never i never it just
didn't feel i never no i didn't feel
like anyone yeah i didn't feel genuine
yeah you you tell it was like only like
i'm sure it was hard she probably gets
actually that's something i'm pretty
sure she gets like yeah
she's been getting made fun of for being
heavy her whole life
yeah yeah it sucks yeah i wouldn't do
that i did
i never thought that was funny don't be
happy though
what yeah i said diet i don't know yeah
i don't know i want you to take that
back he's just
um this is just a elizabeth hurley
appreciation post it's finally good
there's another one wait that's that one
this one's also funny
yeah there's her yeah
she's so phenomenal celebrate that she
is amazing her dime piece son god
i know her finest son
it's true
she is delicious she is so gorgeous dude
she's painfully hot
i mean her skin is like flawless
it's stupid she's your age right she's
two years old older 56 she's older yeah
yeah two years older not a wrinkle on
that [ __ ] face doug i gotta
other times like we'll get to you yeah
father time is still all the time just
like yeah not yet look at her arms look
at her look at her body dude look at
that stomach it's so stupid it's so
stupid
all right that's cool hottest of all
time maybe it's natty or no like any
work done you think she has for her age
whatever it is i don't care
[Laughter]
does that change your mind if it's not
that's no
real
yeah
yeah the way they're falling like that
she's just
falling
she's single
yeah yeah that last time he's single
that's how we look bro you have a shot
dude yeah
uh this is this is really not a current
event or anything it's just i i find
bruce buffer very interesting and
fascinating so he posted this
and i'll just play it for you
[Music]
nobody's paying attention is that legend
sports bar in long beach and i guess
he's announcing his whiskey
or his uh yeah punch size whiskey
or bourbon
no one gives a [ __ ] there's like a
couple people that yelled at the end but
it was just he posted this like it's
like the most coolest thing ever you
keep playing it
oh it's three videos long oh the other
ones are pictures
you got a couple people
it's [ __ ] tough out there man
it's just so funny [ __ ] tough no my
thing about bruce is that i love him
it's so cool i love the phone i love
everything about him i i just in that
video i'm not so sure
i believe his eyes look like it's a
green screen
his eyes he just doesn't look like he
wants to be there
seriously i wish hey bruce
i will direct you
you need me to direct you in the next
day you need something because i i just
he looks like he's just like i don't
really want to do this but i'm going to
do this he has to push that whiskey man
i feel like he does enjoy it it's just
he's just not reading the ones
bruce bruce buffer is as good at that
job
the ufc would not be the same without
that no way the fighters love them dana
rogan and bruce are the most important
elements in the ufc 100 and you've got
to give bruce buffer credit for that
yeah incredible that is so difficult
but don't do that ever again
at least well that's big legends that's
boring that's being cropped though the
guy's already just being advised the
wrong way i would never let him do that
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't let him do it
he posts a lot of stuff like this it's
super fascinating i'd have to hear the
sales
well there's this yesterday cool
poncho's chance mm-hmm
hey i bet you
there's two other
there's one's brothers or one other
brother michael buffer who does boxing
matches
um
there's no one from kat
i didn't get to read this one yet but uh
you know about this yeah okay
uh so hope solo basically came out
saying that megan on the team
so but yeah so she came out saying that
megan rapping poor bullied people into
kneeling for the next word but what as i
think says the timeline doesn't add up
however
i believe she said that she's like oh
yeah just because i wasn't on the team
doesn't mean i knew people on the team
that were being bullied by megan to
deal for the national anthem that told
me about well megan lost her subway ads
too yeah so she's taking the hip for it
rappano yeah like subway like you know
because they are in texas all over and
they ain't having that but who's this
for
oh wow i i got no problem if you want to
kneel for the anthem but when you do
that on a national stage in the olympics
personally i i find it offensive
yeah i don't have time for it
move somewhere else yeah do somewhere
else if you don't like it i don't like
her i wouldn't buy something personally
no don't i don't i don't i don't endorse
no i don't respect or endorse her at all
any facet
i mean it's okay but that's also my my
right so she wants to do that and i can
just boycott her too so
i think that's about it it's tough
it's time for me to kyle uh for our
little event against china actually yeah
they're gonna try to push me out the
door today why not try jewelry
i mean no keep the jewelry don't use it
as a weapon
that's what that's where i [ __ ] up i
didn't have jewelry on yeah it weighs me
down a little bit you know all right
kids i'm in l.a late show added we're in
la this friday saturdays very special
guest friday night friday it's job in
france in l.a uh two shows friday friday
at eight friday at 10
saturday 8 saturday at 10 that's at the
haha in los angeles california the next
week is my favorite place in the world
la jolla comedy store thursday one show
friday two shows saturday two shows
those [ __ ] are almost sold out so buy
tickets now
don't be dm me for tickets because we're
gonna go fast then san jose california
this uh san jose improv september 9th
through the 11th then san antonio texas
september 24th through the 25th one show
friday one show saturday then denver
comedy works downtown denver september
30th through october 2nd then they then
scroll down to las vegas so i'll say it
las vegas
las vegas nevada the wise guys october
7th through october 9th
that's it come see me this weekend
houston texas improv august 19 2021
buffalo new york helium comedy club
september 9 10 and 11 denver colorado
comedy works september 23rd 25th in
chicago illinois improv september 30th
october 1st and as usual you can find me
and sam tripoli conspiracy social club
on rockfin r-o-k-f-i-n-dot-com
uh slash conspiracy social club get you
some
bray i'll see you next week august 26th
uh one nighter and then september 8th
san francisco cobbs comedy club i'm not
going any further tin all right
is that it that's it we're out love you
guys
if you just [ __ ] up the sign man jump in
there
get your
arms to get them out set let's go
oh
how many seconds
oh that's a great one right there
is
you know what it was thanks brother all
right
i'm going to lay up everybody i'm going
to snap
all right
trying to get me out
don't put the knife